Speaker 1: We are getting ready for C-PAC.
CPAC is the Conservative Political Action
Conference earlier in the show.
And earlier in the week, I told you about
some of the people that would be speaking.
Donald Trump will be speaking.
Donald Trump Jr. will be speaking.
Kimberly Guilfoyle will be speaking.
You know, Charlie Kirk and different members
of Congress.
Tulsi Gabbard will be speaking sort of a shock
to some because she was a Democrat and ran
as a Democrat.
But of course, she's extremely reactionary
and fits in much better with the Fox News
crowd than with any leftist.
I know she will be speaking at CPAC, so the
speakers are one side of it.
My colleague John pointed out to me that he
was looking at the sponsors list for CPAC
and a lot of them are the usual suspects.
But there are some pretty weird stuff.
So, you know, if you look at the sponsors
page, you see that Fox Nation is sponsoring.
That's Fox News's streaming platform.
You see that some of the big sponsors are
the Japanese conservative union.
That might sound weird, but there's actually
a big Trump Japan movement the Republican
National Committee is sponsoring and, you
know, a whole bunch of others.
You look at partnering sponsors and the Epic
Times, which are a right wing media outlet
getter, which is like a right wing Twitter.
They're all sponsoring.
You then look at supporting sponsors and it's
a lot of the common ones.
Heritage Foundation and other think tanks,
Tea Party Patriots action on and on.
You look at contributing sponsors and it's
turning Point USA and others.
You then look at participating sponsors and
you still see some names you recognize right
side broadcasting network and others.
And then you go to exhibitors and there's
a whole list of stuff that we don't really
recognize.
And one of them in particular caught my eye,
caught Jon's eye and he told me about it.
And it's called enemies within the church.
This is just unbelievable, and we could pick
any one of these and do this.
But let's just look at this one.
Enemies within the church is, I guess you
would call it, a documentary film.
And what they seem to be arguing is the church
has now been infected with left wing propaganda.
The film, which we're going to look at the
trailer of here, feels that the institution
of the church is too liberal and it's basically
going communist just like they feel our colleges
have this.
This is incredible.
Who would fund this trash?
Look at the trailer?
Let's listen.
Speaker 3: What happened to the church?
To the living powerful, transformative nation
shaking Christianity?
What they're trying to do is completely demolish
Western civilization and to rebuild it in
a just society.
How do you break down American Christianity?
I think the
problem today in our culture is many of our
words have been co-opted and stolen and dumbed
down and reversed.
Social justice is sold as something bad.
It isn't.
Speaker 1: Critical race This is dystopia
porn over the church being to liver liberal.
Understand that that's the core here.
Speaker 3: Theory is sold as something bad.
It isn't.
Whiteness has caused blindness of heart.
Whiteness have caused blindness.
When you preach victimization, it always leads
to vengeance.
Invites us against them, on me, against you.
I want my pound of flesh.
American churches today are where the universities
were 10 years ago, pretty heavily Marxist.
They're not quite there yet, but they are
well on the way.
Many of the seminaries and Bible colleges
are definitely already there.
That message that they're going out and taking
the world is not you need to repent of your
sin, receive Christ instead.
The message that you actually have is they
are under the weight of racism or sexism or
homophobia.
And then we need to unify them together.
I'm gay.
I'm 29.
I'm a youth pastor in New Jersey.
Speaker 1: Oh, nothing more dangerous than
a gay youth pastor.
Guys, these people are really out there.
And this is the new target.
The church liberal churches is the new enemy.
Speaker 3: I'm straight and I'm also you assuming
kasi.
We're planning ushering life together for
the rest of our lives, which we're not totally
sure that looks like.
Obviously, they just straight, and he does
plan on getting married when he has a wife.
One day she'll make those decisions with us.
The future damage of what we're doing now
is just going to be enormous.
The entire fabric of family, personal wealth,
private property, all those things are obvious.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that when you stake
out the position.
That college now, colleges liberal indoctrination
you send your kids to college is going to
be a real problem there.
Can't do it.
Regular elementary school No, no, no, no,
no kids are being taught about slavery and
you got a home school.
Christian Home Schooling Church will church
is fine, right?
That's the safe place for this idea.
Now the churches are becoming Marxist social
justice places.
And though you got to keep your kids out of
that, they are going in the direction of the
only place.
That's OK is some small cult like enclave
that is quite frankly reminiscent of of Jim
Jones, right?
The drink, the Kool-Aid people.
At the end of the day, that's what they are
building here.
You're only safe in your little cult.
Even the churches is dangerous now,
Speaker 3: and everything is the state.
They believe the state is God.
They don't define justice the same way as
the scripture.
Oh no, it's going to be an equality.
All right.
And it's going to be a totalitarian Marxist
justice.
Speaker 1: So that's just and again, we could
we could look at a ton of these.
That's one spot exhibitor at C-PAC.
The people who feel churches are become and
they use, they use all sorts of communist
imagery there as well, if you were just listening.
The church has become a communist Marxist
social justice entry way into dangerous leftism,
according to these folks.
Now the funny thing is, if this actually had
the effect of weakening the lobbying power
of churches, it might actually be a good thing.
The problem is what they're advocating is
get out of those churches, come to the right
churches, make sure they remain fully funded,
et cetera.
We're going to be covering CPAC and it's going
to be insane.
The sponsors are insane.
The exhibitors are radical.
It's all crazy.
But as I said yesterday, we don't have this
level of organization on the left.
We we just don't we and we need it.
And part of why the country keeps going to
the left but they keep winning elections is
because they have this level of organization,
they have this level of funding and it's not
at some point it will hurt the left.
It is hurting the left.
It has hurt the left for a very long time.